to the extent that there's a positive to
take out of this whole pandemic it's
obviously been the heroic work of the
medical professionals the doctors the
nurses the people that work at the
hospital on a day to day basis so today
I thought we would focus on one of these
stories and head to Houston where I grew
up to talk with an old elementary school
friend of mine brent kaznia he's a
doctor there he works at the Texas
Children's Hospital and along with
people on his team and and other people
at the hospital they came up with
open-source designed for a protective
system for people who are performing
intubations to make sure the virus
wasn't spreading in the air and so with
that let's go talk to Brent and hear a
story besides being an illustrious
alumni Laurel Drive elementary do you
mind introducing yourself and telling us
kind of what you do over there yeah sure
so I'm the medical director of emergency
management at Texas Children's Hospital
and what that really means is that just
when there are disaster things that
happen you know hurricane flooding
what-have-you I kind of helped the
organization respond to that yep but
obviously this is quite a different
situation
a whole different ballgame I mean we're
used to we are super prepared for
hurricanes here you know we do indle
drills on hurricanes I can you know
obviously happen annually here but you
know I don't think any of us really kind
of it really started laying the
groundwork for a response of like this
magnitude I mean it's just kind of nuts
what we're going through right now
across the country in the world some of
the early reports were like it doesn't
seem to affect children as much and I
mean what was your experience like I
think the good news through this whole
thing is that kids don't seem to be as
markedly impacted as adults we're now
seeing these case reports this
inflammatory disease process
inflammatory system response that some
kids are having their reports out of New
York and UK
about that and so we're obviously kind
of gearing up towards that and making
sure we're not gonna miss any cases of
those or kids that might progress to
that and and so just kind of going back
you started seeing some pictures coming
out of intubating people and I mean tell
me the story I think you saw these
pictures and it kind of Concerned you
that maybe yeah I mean you know really
one of the things that we were realizing
is that you know our providers that
intubate regularly sort putting you know
Airways in and things they're at high
risk of exposure right their secretions
your suctioning all this stuff and
people were starting to get you know
really freaked out about that their
potential for contracting this illness
from patients and so I just kind of been
looking on the internet and somebody
sent me something it was actually a
physician in Taiwan it made this just
Plexiglas rectangular box with kind of
two arm holes I was like that's a really
interesting idea but I don't know that
like urgh anomaly this would make sense
for the way that I would put my arms and
hands and I don't know if the access is
limiting and so you see these pictures
you're like you know I don't think this
is gonna work for me let's try something
else and so what did you just literally
start sketching so that out on a piece
of paper or so starting with some paper
and some sketches then I got it I
literally went to our office supply
closet and took all the paper reams out
of a cardboard box and started hacking
it up and taping it together with duct
tape I mean our facilities team is
amazing and five days we went from
cardboard box to functional working
prototype and so out of this came the
airway rest pretty content system or the
arc as we call it yes what I mean walk
me through just a little bit of the
specifics of how it works so you
essentially put the device over the
patient's head and there's support holes
for personnel to get in there and
there's two other holes that I think are
really important to you and those holes
we use to create negative pressure so we
hook a viral filter up to one of those
holes and then some tubing that you hook
up to the wall suction and so it's
essentially sucking you know anything
that's air slides should get sucked out
of there so it's not going to come at
you when you take the device off right
so put it on I get in there I put the
airway in hook it up to the ventilator
take the box off and it's ready for the
next patient we're not trying to make
money off of it there's no IP like it's
an open source project that we're just
sharing right so world yeah I mean you
guys are open sourced it so you'd like
basically that means you just put up
like the the CAD drawings or the the
sacks and everything behind it and then
and there's a company called leggings
called Sawbones right that's actually
they're making it yeah so they tweaked
our final design they kind of made a
professional cat of it
and now they have it on their website if
you want to download the sketch and make
it yourself in your wood shop just like
we did you can or you can buy one from
them you know and it's 130 bucks and
then and this is the device you guys are
using in the hospital on kind of a
day-to-day basis yes we've got four and
they're being used in the operating
rooms across the institution now and
like I mean other hospitals heard about
this yet have they been able to order
some as well it's all happening so
quickly
I think there's interest you know I
think in healthcare in particular
hospital based healthcare we tend to be
lagging when it comes to innovation and
technology and my hope is that like in
the post kovat era we'll be able to use
things like this as an example and say
like look guys we push this through and
got it done